If you're learning a language,
try live online lessons with italki.
Use today's technology to take lessons
conveniently from home.
Buy one lesson and get one free.
Link in the description.
[music playing]
Hello everyone. Welcome to the Langfocus channel.
And my name is Paul
Today's topic is: How similar are French and Italian?
Well, they are actually very similar.
They share a lot of common vocabulary
and the grammar is very similar.
But, in terms of phonology, they are quite different.
So, in their spoken form,
they are generally not mutually intelligible.
French and Italian are both Romance Languages.
They both developed out of the Vulgar Latin
spoken throughout the Roman Empire.
But, French kind of stands out as different
from other Romance Languages.
The historical land of Gaul
is located inside modern day France.
And one theory is that,
when the Roman Empire  conquered Gaul
and tried to force the local population to speak Latin,
they spoke it using Gaulish speech sounds
And that has affected the phonology and the pronunciation of French until this day.
Gaulish was a Celtic language.
So that means that there is
some Celtic influence in the French language.
Specifically, in phonology.
In any case, French and Italian are very closely related.
Let's have a look at just how close they are.
Vocabulary.
Italian and French are very similar
in terms of vocabulary.
The lexical similarity of the two languages
is eighty-nine percent.
That means that 89 % of the words used
have equivalents or cognates in the other language.
That doesn't mean the words are exactly
the same but they are clearly related.
Some obvious examples:
Good day / Hello
Interesting
To eat.
And there are some less obvious cognates too.
Hospital
hour
At what time?
To search (for), look for.
I think the figure of 89% is probably true
if we include formal literary vocabulary.
But in daily conversation, it seems to be a little lower.
Let's look at these examples:
[...]
So here you can see that most of the words have
an equivalent except for the words that are in red.
Those ones are different.
Like the word for "here".
In Italian, it's "qui" and in French, it's "ici".
And the word for "with".
In Italian, it's "con" and in French, it's "avec".
The word for "in".
In Italian, it's "in" and in French, it's "dans"
Aside from those words, the other words
are all basically equivalent.
Except for a couple of definite articles
which are used differently
I recommend that you pause the video now. Look at
the two sentences along with an English break down.
And see what you notice about the equivalence.
Here are another couple examples.
So again, these sentences are quite similar
but a few of the words are different.
"dimenticate": that means "forget" in Italian
and "oubliez" means "forget" in French.
And again, we see the different words for "in".
The Italian word "in" and the French word "dans".
And we see different words for "store".
The Italian word "negozio" and the French word "magasin"
So again, why don't you pause the video
and have a look at the two sentences,
and see what you can learn by comparing them?
So you can see that, in a typical sentence,
the majority  of vocabulary used is similar
to the vocabulary used in the other language.
But not all of it.
Grammar
In French and Italian, the word order and
the sentence structure are generally very similar.
Here's a simple sentence to show similar word order.
The sentence means "I have a newspaper for the trip"
And you can see that these sentences
are - word for word - translatable.
But there are also some grammatical differences too.
In French, subject pronouns are consistently used.
But, in Italian, subject pronouns generally aren't used,
except for emphasis.
So, in French: "..." , In Italian "..."
I speak English.
But "Io" is not usually said. So it's just "Parlo inglese"
And there's another difference in pronouns.
In French, the 2nd person formal
and plural pronoun is "vous".
In Italian, the third person pronoun "Lei"
is used for the second person formal.
So, in French we'd have:
but in Italian:
So, the Italian sentence is like "SHE speaks too slowly"
But it should be clear from the context
that you are saying "you" and not "she",
because you're talking to someone directly.
Also, in Italian, direct object pronouns are also normally
attached to the end of a verb when it's in the infinitive form.
In French,  we'd have :
but, in Italian, we'd have:
Negation is also a little different in the two languages.
In French, we'd say:
with "ne" and "pas" to show negation.
But, in Italian, we'd say:
So, in French, we have "ne" and "pas"
but, in Italian, there's no equivalent of "pas"
Those are some little differences, but other major things
like the verb tenses are basically the same.
French and Italian share the same 14  verb tenses.
Of course, they're not conjugated exactly the same
but the tenses function in the same way.
For example, let's look at how the past tense is formed.
In French "..." , in Italian "..."
(You have eaten something)
This means "You ate something",
spoken to one person informally
The verb consists of two parts:
First, the 2nd person singular form of the word for "have"
and second, the past participle
Obviously, the forms are different but the way you use
them together to create the past tense is the same.
And just as a quick side note,
notice how to say "something" in the two languages:
"quelque chose" versus "qualcosa".
French and Italian grammar is very similar,
just like the vocabulary is largely similar
Pronunciation
The biggest difference between French and Italian
and the one that prevents mutual intelligibility the most
is pronunciation
Italian pronunciation is mostly phonetic
and mirrors the written words exactly
French words are pronounced differently
from the way they're written.
And you have to keep some phonetic rules
in mind when pronouncing words.
Most Italian words end in a vowel, which makes it easy
to pronounce the end of the word.
In French, there are many consonants,
that are usually silent at the end of a word
For example, this sentence meaning "the weather is called"
In Italian "...", in French "..."
Notice that the "d" sound at the end of "froid" is silent.
Another example is the phrase for "white wine"
In Italian "vino bianco" ; in French "vin blanc"
Hear that the final "c" is silent. So the last sound we hear
is the nasal sound represented by "n".
"Vin" also ends in a nasal sound.
The "n" is not pronounced as a consonant here.
Instead, it nasalizes the preceding vowel
So rather than "..." , it's "..."
There are also some other sounds
that are quite different in French.
For example the French "r". It's not the same
as the rolled "r" that you would find in Italian.
In Italian, you produce the r by flapping the tip of
your tongue against the roof of your mouth behind your teeth
But, the French "r" is a guttural "r"
that's produced at the back of your mouth.
In Italian "...", in French ""  (to go away, to leave)
So those final silent consonants, as well as the nasal sounds,
the French "r", those are some differences with Italian.
but they're are also some of the things that learners
find challenging about French pronunciation.
Let's finish by just breaking down a couple more sentences
and seeing what similarities and differences we notice.
Here's a sentence meaning:
"What are your favorite dishes?"
In Italian "..." ; in French "..."
So, word by word, the sentence is:
what are your (plural) dishes (plural) preferred (plural)
"Quali" and "Quels" are equivalents,
but notice that the plural ending is different.
In Italian, it's often "i" or "e"
but, in French, it's a silent "s"
"sono" and "sont" are equivalent
but notice that "sono" ends in a vowel
while "sont" ends in a nasal sound a silent "t".
"i vostri" and "vos" are equivalent
but, in Italian, the definite article is normally
used with a possessive pronoun like "vostri",
while, in French, there's no definite article.
"piatti" and "plat" are equivalent
but notice the different plural endings and notice
that words with "i" an Italian often have an "l" in French.
We've seen another example of that:
"bianco" in Italian and "blanc" in French.
"preferiti" and "préférés" are obvious equivalents,
just with different accent markings and a different ending.
Now, here's one more pair of sentences
but, this time, I want you to have a look at them
and notice the similarities and differences
without me breaking it down for you.
in Italian
in French  !!! déjeuner (with é accent) !!!
So I hope this video has made it clear just
how similar French and Italian really are.
The speaker of one of them can probably
learn the other quite easily.
And, in writing, the level of mutual intelligibility is quite high.
But, because the cognate words are all a little bit different,
because the pronunciation of the two languages is so different,
the two languages are not mutually
intelligible in their spoken form.
But, as a learner of Italian, my previous knowledge of French
makes a lot of things in Italian instantly clear to me.
So, the question of the day
for speakers of French and Italian:
how similar do you consider the two languages to be?
And to learners of French and Italian:
does your knowledge of one of those languages help you
make any sense of the other or help you understand the other?
Share your experiences in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow lang focus
on Instagram, on Twitter and on Facebook.
And again thank you to all of my patreon supporters
for continuing to make this channel possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.